Scott what's the difference between
critique versus trolling nowadays who
knows
um
I I feel like some critics are almost
trolls at this point because once they
get their mind made up about things
they seem like they can
understand or respect someone else's
and I I really do feel like social media
is is the blame for that because
everyone has become an expert
and I think I'm probably
one of
part of the last generation where
I went to school for film criticism
and I studied film I grew up watching
film and I didn't just wake up one
morning and say you know tomorrow I'm
going to start a blog and I'm going to
write about movies and then everyone's
going to accept me as a Critic
I went to
school for it whether it was Chapman
University or Kutztown University where
I got my masters
and I studied film I studied Film
Production I studied film criticism I
spent years watching movies and and
reading books about it
and in the last
15 years that almost like kind of went
out the window because
and I I will say that I think YouTube
was the start of it
YouTube allowed and I know as part of
this initial buzz on YouTube
allowed the everyday person to be able
to record a video and give their opinion
on something sure you had live Journal
beforehand
or Myspace or whatever
but YouTube kind of was this thing that
caught on and nothing has been able to
to over overtake it right I mean out of
all the videos Platforms in the world
YouTube has has holds held strong for 15
years
but I remember this because
I remember watching a lot of people who
are my colleagues now
doing YouTube video reviews
whether it was the smose Christian and
Mark whether it was Jeremy Johns Chris
stuckman
and they are all kind of people who felt
this love
of movies
but they their their whole selling point
was
where the average Joe we're the you know
the smose thing was always we're the
spouse we're the average guy
we're not the film critics we're not the
hoity-toity and I think for a period of
time it was great because there was a
group of them who I think did their
homework and they were really
prioritize in doing this but then the
floodgates opened
and everyone who liked movies
decided that they were going to become
a movie reviewer
and I think we're going to do it as a
career
so we turned into an industry where so
many people
are
putting their time and effort
into film and criticism
that number one don't really have a long
history of it they have no backing they
have no schooling behind it
but I think the most
troubling part of all this is who don't
make money from it
so
there's only so many jobs just like
there's only so many movies and so many
acting roles and so many directing roles
and whatnot
there's only so many places for
film critics
and with newspapers kind of falling
and going away
you don't have as many critics working
for those sources anymore so you have
trades
you saw what happened to Entertainment
Weekly they're now all digital
all these websites that popped up
they're all digital some of them went
under but got sold to other companies
they keep getting sold over and over and
over again
so there's a very limited amount of
space that people can actually critique
stuff
and yet everyone feels like they want
their voice heard so they create their
own blog or their own movie website
and then they get
in a weird way they get devastated
because they're like oh I can't make a
living this is what I love I want to do
it right and
then you got people doing gofundme's and
kickstarters and all this stuff to kind
of like hey I want to go this event I
want to go here can you give me money to
do this
and these people don't have
money they can they can't support
themselves and they want to do this so
it's like it's weird in a weird way like
when I was growing up we always remember
seeing actors and everyone always every
hearing everyone like I I know I talked
about Jim Carrey
Jim Carrey like sleeping in his car and
he wanted to be an actor right he just
he knew he wanted to be an actor and the
struggle of that
it's weird because now we're like film
critics where they're like we'll do
anything for it and it's very strange
but
I realized I didn't answer the question
about trolls versus film film critics
to me
a troll is someone who like loves
something
and like hates anyone who has a
different opinion of that and will kind
of seek out
and want to destroy a person
for not sharing the same view or the
same love that they have for something
a Critic should be able to look at
something subjectively
regardless of whether they like
an actor an actress
a filmmaker and judge a full product
and look at it and say
is the script good is the score good is
the production design good is the acting
good
and be able to kind of call out the
weaknesses and the strengths
of whatever that project is
and I think there's a very big
difference because I've noticed
fandom has gone so far past
just being a Star Wars movie or Star
Wars TV show or DC
it's gone to like individual people like
I cannot tell you how many times I have
been attacked
by people who I don't mind as actors or
I like as actors but I don't like
something they do
and like this Hive mentality comes after
you like the last the most recent one
was Lady Gaga this past year for House
of Gucci
I love Lady Gaga I think Lady Gaga is a
gifted singer she's a great actress
how's the Gucci just didn't showcase her
strongest moments and it was kind of
laughably bad at times
you put that out and it's like they just
don't freak and they come at you oh you
like Kristen Stewart how dare you she's
a terrible actress and it's like they
find everything they can
to use against you
and it's just it's like this so mean
spirited and so much hate
that it's almost like
after a while
it works against them because like you
actually now have like this negative
reaction towards this person because
their fans are so shitty towards you
because you're like I like this person I
just didn't like this one thing and all
these people are like sitting here
attacking me now
and like you almost want to like would
they don't seem to realize too is that
the people doing this
we usually have the opportunity at some
point whether it's at an award show
whether it's at a junket to talk to
these to these talents
so it's weird because I think if I ever
talk to Lady Gaga I think I would say to
her
you know probably at the end of the
interview or something like that I said
by the way
you know do you realize how shitty your
fans are
because like I literally said I didn't
like you in one thing but I still
support you and I still think you're
great in these other things and these
people came out at me sending me you
know death threats and like calling me
like the worst person on the planet and
all this stuff so I think that's that's
the really big difference is that as as
a Critic
even if you love someone
you have to be able to acknowledge that
they're not going to be on their game
all the time
you know I love Tim Burton as a director
but
sometimes he doesn't make good movies
Alice in Wonderland not a good movie
Dark Shadows not a good movie doesn't
mean I hate Tim Burton it just means
those movies didn't work and that
happens with everything you can be a
Marvel fan and think that Thor is a
terrible movie you can be a Marvel fan
and and hate Ant-Man it doesn't matter
like you can still love the product and
the brand
they're never gonna nothing's perfect in
this world you're never gonna have a 10
out of 10 every time
and I think people need to understand
that I think that's the importance of
criticism is that you have to be able to
look at an individual
film
and judge it on its own Merit it's it's
not about
this person's body of work like I'm
going to judge all of Leonardo DiCaprio
just because he was in you know Shutter
Island that's it that's it that's the
movie I'm judging him on no you have to
look at everyone and all they've done
but also look at the individual project
and judge that on its own
has trolling become a hobby
yes a lot of them go too far and
sometimes
you get caught up in the moment of it
right like it's very weird as
someone who is a fan of of people who
are popular within the industry uh
whether it's a Taylor Swift The Kristen
Stewart or Tim Burton
um Steven Spielberg whoever
you you almost like when they have
something you want to Champion you're
almost like you almost become
part of the the you know the hive we
were talking about the hive you almost
become part of that Hive because
I wanted Kristen Stewart so badly to win
the Oscar right that like even though
all the signs were pointing in the in
the direction that likes does not
happening right she's not established
enough she doesn't have enough people in
the industry don't like her like all
these things are pointed in the
direction that she was gonna do it yet
like you believe so strongly in the
person and you want to Champion them so
hard
is that like
you have to like Let It Go and the thing
is and that's the difference that I
think between
regular like critics and and journalists
and and people who are fans versus
trolls is that you can support someone
and you can like literally post about
them every day if you love them that
much
but at the end of the time like there's
got to be a point where you can cut it
off so like okay Kristen Stewart lost
she didn't win the Oscar
you can't sit there for the next year
posting about like oh she should have
won every day and there's people who do
and I think it's very very unhealthy
that people become so obsessed
with celebrities and films and pop stars
and all this stuff because
you have to have focus elsewhere it's
just what you need to fo you know you
need to have like a life outside of
these things these are these are
I don't even know how to put it but
these are
these are moments in your life right
like seeing a movie exists in in that
moment for the two hours or two and a
half
hours
and you can like you can like it and you
can talk about it and until you're blue
in the face but you have to have
something else you have to have
something else you look for whether it's
a partner whether it's going out to eat
whether it's going to play sports you
have to and I'm really kind of worried
about some of
those in this in this industry and
especially the trolls who seem like they
don't have anything else to do with
their time and they have no other
Ambitions but to sit here
and like support someone who I hate to
say it probably doesn't even know you
exist and even if they know you exist
they meet you they say hi
they're thankful that you're supporting
them
but they're going home afterwards and
they're not going to say for the next
six months thinking about oh there's
Julie I remember remember Julie we met
Julia that's screening and she was so
sweet I'm going to talk about Julie
every day for six like no she's
literally like okay met a really nice
guy you know met that really nice guy
there had a great moment with him he was
really nice that's it come up in
conversation once ever you know that's
it